[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
guys thanks for uh tuning in again uh
the last two weeks
actually last few weeks ryan had been
pretty big episodes
a lot of support a lot of love out there
i love that people are subscribing and
uh you know not only coming to the show
because of a certain guest but going hey
i like that
i'd like to listen to some more
interviews even if i don't know every
person or
so i appreciate everybody out there and
uh
yeah that's nice uh how's your week bud
good
same you know same you know
yeah well this will have aired a few
days
after when we're recording this right
now
but i post something because i am
convinced i saw a ufo
i know you saw the picture the video did
you did you
it's odd it's it's okay so what there's
no noise there's flashing lights that go
sort of like in a like a triangular and
then around
right right i i mean i i have never
seen anything like it i mean my first
thought has always drone these days yeah
but
while i put up a drone and the skies are
opaque with all the smoke and [ __ ] the
the
air quality i don't think at 11 30 at
night there's gonna be some drone above
my house
i don't know who buys drones no buys
drugs
anyway it was crazy i was outside it was
watching my dog taking [ __ ] because
that's what i that's how i roll
and um and i look up and i go what the
[ __ ]
my friend shira stopped by and uh get my
phone and i used her shitty phone she
might as well have had a flip [ __ ]
phone you know those flip phones
it's brutal my dude update do something
i don't know but uh you know this week
the last two weeks i felt bad because
you know i i sort of you know told
i just i said what was going on in my
life you know it was like you know the
skin cancer then last week my sister
passed away and again it was this show
is
is like that i can't not share that
information and uh
um everything you know it's nice this
this week i think you know my dad's
i'm sure there's some sort of relief you
know and uh because
my sister was six for so long and um
but you know i've been talking to him
every day and uh
i think you know he'll he'll get he'll
get he'll get better and better you just
have to know there's always tomorrow
um so everything else is is fine
uh again thanks to all the patrons out
there if you don't know what patreon is
uh it's extra support for the show and
you get a bunch of stuff like
inside of me you get to ask me questions
and i make videos and
answer your questions and then there's
[ __ ] talking with guests you get to ask
guest questions and then there's
occasional zoom or there's a
live youtube for just patreons and a
bunch of stuff
there's a lot of fun stuff great
community and i couldn't do it without
you guys
um they've been around for a while and
um so if you want to join patreon check
it out i think you'll really enjoy it
and
certain tiers get merch boxes every four
months which is oh
fun maybe it's every three months i
don't know so i just packed boxes
yesterday i do it
i might i write these little notes and
hand written
my hand gets [ __ ] tired after [ __ ]
three of them
i'm like i got 20 left to do today i
have to take breaks because i don't hand
you don't
handle you don't do that anymore you
don't do that no but i was putting
things in the box and i got new merch
for you know
because when they get like they're a
dedicated patron you know and
so they get the little box personalized
thing from me and they get
cool [ __ ] so i think people are digging
it and they always have ideas these
patrons
they always and some of them are really
good they're like you know you should do
inside of patrons
i'm like well how would that work that
just seems it seems like more work for
me doesn't it
more work for ryan uh you know but it
was a good idea
um i'll have to figure it out but like
sort of like
asking people how the podcast has
changed their lives like on patreon
maybe ask a certain patron every once in
a while a lottery where
you know you film them and you know just
a couple minutes
how does it change your life and blah
blah you know because uh some people
were really affected and uh so i
appreciated it
i appreciate all of it and remember to
subscribe and uh
follow us at insideypodcast on instagram
at insideapod on twitter we have it
inside of you on facebook as well
well at inside you podcast or insideipod
you'll figure it out
a lot of good stuff on there stage it is
this weekend
this coming weekend rob and i are doing
another stage it's right before we go
into recording studio and and record our
album
so great prizes if you go to stage
it.com
and type in rosenbaum and dance and
there's two shows next saturday the 26th
of september it's uh
uh 2 p.m and a 6 p.m tons of stuff
autograph band pictures and shirts and
zooms and we play a song
for you and we'll send it to you just a
bunch of great stuff so go to stage.com
and get tickets now and uh it's a live
show and it's a lot of fun and thanks
for the support
today's guest i've known her for since
she was a
young girl i think she got smallville
when she was 17.
and i was 25 26.
and um you know we just became
really good friends in the beginning she
was too young and i was
old eccentric guy you know i wasn't old
but
um you know i was bald weird guy i guess
i don't know whatever i was
she and i created this sort of a bond
like we became friends and it was really
nice and uh i think she's a
tremendous human being i don't say this
about a lot of people
but kristen crook has a such a strong
awareness of who she is and who she
aspires to be and what she wants to
become i mean
she just she's always evolving and she's
always
she's always working on herself it seems
like she's she's always
doing things for others other young
women
she uh she's a positive force i think
she really
is a great woman she's got a lot to talk
about so i'm excited about that
were you here for this recording i was
not oh no
well hell with you then ryan uh shout
out right here to ryan who's been uh
doing some
fantastic editing give ryan a hand right
here see there we go
there we go i mean he edits all the uh
you know the videos on youtube and then
you could listen to him and
so he's uh he's got a good ear and i
trust him i don't even listen to the
episodes anymore
i just i assume that you're gonna just
do a great job
and protect me if i say something stupid
which is constantly what no it's all
perfect no it's
i barely do anything that's a lie uh
again thank you everybody for all the
well wishes
for uh just all those nice notes and all
those things
um and some of the cameos have been
fantastic and uh we're doing some more
virtual cons tom and i are doing a
couple so
check out instagram and and twitter and
all that stuff and
we'll let you know but the virtual cons
are fun we're doing these zooms and
they give you i've said it before they
give you like two minutes to talk to
someone
you know they're like hey michael and
they give you a button that you can go
10 extra seconds 10 extra seconds and i
always do that
i shouldn't have told people down but i
i do
go over if you do two minutes in with me
you definitely get more than two minutes
i'll [ __ ] tell you that right now
all right let's get inside of the
wonderful talented
my former co-star i hope i uh get to
work with her again someday she's a joy
and uh this is kristin crook
let's get inside of kristen crook it's
my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you know this whole thing the whole kova
the whole you know how the world is now
and i'm i'm optimistic i
talk about we talk about this on the
podcast i don't know how do you do it
how do you react to this [ __ ] i
just most of the time i'm
able to just move forward
like i try not to get stuck in it and i
think that
that's like when i talk to people who
really get
caught up in it it's like the difference
between me and them
in those moments is that i don't
keep thinking about it like i just
go okay that's just the way it is right
now and i can step
back and not get completely invested i'm
not like that all the time
but with certain things that feel very
out of my control
i am i am you let them
go quickly yeah i let them go why do i
linger on them like a cranberry song
that i don't know michael why do you i
don't know i think because my mind's
going
a million miles an hour i'm doing all
these things and um
it's not that i expect everything to be
smooth sailing and
and happen and and be fine and be great
and i know there are things along the
way there bumps along the road
on the road whatever but i i think
i do get a little overwhelmed at things
it you know especially when
when that hits when it's one thing after
another i try to do the breathing i try
and then also i'm drinking a coke
i'm uh you know i'm not exercising as
much and i kind of go down i'm like what
are you doing and if you just kind of
realize maybe that
hey stop go back to the routine go back
to do you have a routine
yeah i was gonna say though i think a
part of what i do too though is i don't
overload myself
i don't like having a ton of stuff on my
plate and so i try and keep it so that i
don't like i don't like it when i have
it like i do get stressed out when i
have a lot so i kind of control my life
a little bit so that i don't
have those moments that you're talking
about we're all piles on top of each
other
because then i feel like i'm scrambling
and i can't keep up so like part of how
i manage it is i just don't have
as many things that i'm doing like i
feel like you do a lot of things
okay i think you're caught in your first
lie because you're going back to school
you're
on a show you uh you know i mean you do
a lot of things
but maybe you are able to not spread
yourself too thin and go i could handle
this i could handle this and when
something you can't
right yeah i guess maybe it's more like
i have a sense of what i can handle and
i
i don't push myself too far beyond what
i think i can handle
that's good do you get annoyed easily i
mean i know you do
because you got annoyed with me
sometimes on the set
but sometimes especially if i'm tired
do you know yeah or when you're hungry
yes
i i get like that we get we get angry
but like you're dating someone
do you do you find yourself like why why
did i just get annoyed oh i'm sorry
that was such a small thing you did but
for some reason it pissed me off
absolutely
especially during covid that's
definitely
it's more annoying like why are you
eating the cake
while it's in the fridge why not remove
it from the fridge
and then eat the cake is this necessary
to oh there's a printer going off in my
office that's fine yeah oh
so yes the answer is yes well if i were
him i'd say cause i'm a guy
this is what we do i have an arnold
palmer it's a jug of arnold palmer iced
tea
of course i live alone it's different
but i
open the fridge and i give a little
chuggy chug because no one else is gonna
go in there and probably drink my ice
tea unless they ask me and then i'll say
hey i just chugged on that you might
wanna be right but are you spilling your
iced tea
into the fridge okay now we're getting
somewhere so you're saying
he's a little bit messy he spills cake
in the fridge it's really irrelevant in
the grand scheme of life
but in the moment at times it can be
annoying
yeah i think what's funnier is the
conversation maybe you have an hour
later where you're like
um sweetheart i don't know if you call
him sweetheart maybe honey bunny
but perhaps you just say the keg
incident
i mean you're you're a pig but i
shouldn't have reacted like that and
um sorry about the cake fight yeah i
mean it doesn't ever get to
fight fight land but definitely it is it
is strange
so you don't fight i think we we don't
have like
fight fights um we'll like disagree
or have an argument about something but
we don't like i don't
like we don't have yelling fights i
can't imagine you yelling
i would love if just on this podcast one
time you just laid into me
yeah i won't do that that's highly
unlikely you never yell when's the last
time you yelled
at work because it was in a scene oh
it was the writing i liked the uh so so
so you were in a moment and you had to
yell because it's written and you're
acting yelling
yeah i've yelled in previous in previous
relationships
you know it's come to yelling um
but only if someone else yells first
right i mean you had a good upbringing
were your parents yellers
no they were they were quietly punishing
quietly punishing that sounds like a
song when you say that
you do something and in in a very subtle
way
not to say they could shame you but
they'll say something that's just
oh they know how to get under my skin
without doing anything much of anything
yeah but there were lots of rules in my
household you had to follow the rules
what were the rules please you can't go
out
can't date people you can't wear makeup
you can't do anything you can't watch
certain shows if there's kissing in them
well didn't you kiss tom on smallville
oh that's different that's when i'm
older when you're an adult it's fine
there's rules when you're like
growing up in a household but you still
live with your parents for uh
until you were what 19 yeah but my
parents are very interesting they they
have a they're very clear like
when a kid turns 18 they are an adult
and when they're an adult everything
stops
they're they don't try and parent they
don't
get too involved they don't demand my
time or my energy
they're like you do your life we'll
support you in the ways you want to be
supported and we'll back off if you want
us to back off and i feel
no pressure from that wait a minute so
it's like
when's your birthday again december 30th
right december 3rd i wanted to say
earlier december but i'm glad you said
it first because then i didn't look
wrong
so on december 29th they might have been
kind of rude and said you're going to do
this you're going to do that and then
the second you turn
uh 18 now leave her alone
pretty much that was their theory and
and i'm really as i
see some of my friends and their
relationships with their parents like
i'm really
glad that they did that like i just
don't feel
the weight of them at all did you feel
that teenage
angst did you feel that they won't let
me do anything
i want to do this did you ever find
yourself yelling at them as a kid yeah
of course
i was i was an annoying child because i
called
my parents i'm not an annoying adult
um i called my parents out on a lot of
stuff
i would be like this is an inconsistent
rule and like what is the like basically
like what's what's the basis of your
rule and and if i'm upholding the basis
of your rule
then am i not doing what i'm supposed to
be doing and i get mad at them and i'd
have like big arguments about
what i thought was uh objectionable
parenting
um but yeah i mean i wanted to do things
and i did i found ways to do things
but i wasn't like uh the thing is i
always really saw myself as a
responsible teenager
you were all teenagers right you were
very
you're a responsible person ultimately
right yeah
i think i i try to be yes do you ever go
back and say
mom dad i want to say thank you
for quietly punishing me over the years
i have i have said thank you i mean i've
had some really interesting
conversations
becoming choosing this profession has
been weird because my
my my parents don't understand why i
would ever choose to be in the public
eye
and oftentimes i don't understand why i
chose that either
um and so it's been nice to be able to
talk to them about
those choices and how their parenting
has allowed me to feel more grounded in
that and to be able to
make decisions that make me
feel safe and comfortable
as opposed to feeling like i need to
constantly
amass more you know shows as an actor or
whatever it is
did they give you that approval did they
say did they watch them all do they say
hey we're really proud of you you're
very talented
we liked watching the show good job uh
that's sort of stuff that i didn't get
yeah i guess but i think it was more for
them i mean they watch the shows
i think partly it's because i don't live
at home anymore and they just want to
see my face
um but my my dad was very clear with me
actually recently too he was like
i'm not that he's not proud of things we
do necessarily it's more about how we
are and if we're choosing things that
are making
positive impacts in our communities wow
so you learned a lot of that from them
from your dad oh yeah i mean my dad's
both of them
are very engaged but my dad was always
heavily involved in our community so he
was a landscape where he is a landscape
architect and
he'd work on the parks board and just
ensure that he was like engaged in the
community
um on a very on the ground level so that
the
community itself would thrive and be
better that was important to him well i
thought you know i'm asking these
questions because obviously you know
it's therapy but uh you know when i grow
when i
grow up you heard it there's a there was
a slip
uh you know when i was growing up i i
think there's an essence of that i've
definitely
matured a little bit not much but
you always want to get your father's
approval you want them to be proud of
you
you want your dad to say i love you you
want these things
do you think that's something that
you're really after a certain age you
just didn't
uh didn't need anymore is it something
we all still
sort of want for instance like when
you're dating people
did you want them to date someone that
you liked that they oh sorry that they
liked
like my dad would like him i'm gonna
date him because my dad would like him
i think that is a part of it for sure i
even made a conscious decision in that
way
once i was like weighing
options for myself and a part of it is
like how
well would my family get along with this
person
would they like them and do they have
like values that
are shared with with my with my family
like that was
important to me okay so we're so
different in regard in that regard in a
lot of regards
the difference for me was can this
person i'm dating
would she leave me once she met my
family
is there a possibility that she might
say okay
i could deal with it really you still
you still like me you still want to hang
out with me
even though yeah you know that was the
opposite yeah
i can understand why it would be
different from i've never
met your parents um
but from everything that i hear like it
does
it just sounds like we have very
different different yeah and look people
grow i've talked about it my dad's
growing i think my mom tries to make
i think that you know what you can't
change people
you just can't this is who they are and
uh if i you know as a young girl my
parents are crazy or
or if you're dating someone like i'm
dating someone she's just crazy
right i'm not saying that i'm saying if
you if you it's all hypothetical
but if you continue to either try to
change them or expect a different
outcome and
you're you're crazier you're
someone's not just gonna go oh okay i'm
gonna completely be a different person
now for you
no never i think it's unfair to them too
like if
if you're going like i like these
aspects of this individual
and i don't like these so i'm going to
try and
control them to be other than that then
it's so unfair there's probably
a relationship or something for them
somewhere else where they can be
loved for who they are as a whole not
me being like you have to be another way
your sister did you have a great
relationship growing up or was it sort
of like
sometimes maybe she wasn't even acting
this way but you felt like
i had to kind of lessen how
good smallville is or important small
was or any work beauty and the beast or
whatever show you're working on did you
feel like you had to just kind of go ah
it's not a big deal whatever let's not
talk about it
because you almost or with friends or
anything do you ever feel like that i
think we we inadvertently do that don't
we
well uh i think okay with my sister
she's five years younger than me
she's in a very different profession um
i don't think she particularly likes my
work
wait a minute she doesn't like your work
she's told you like i don't think you're
good
she never said that i mean obviously i'm
me
i interpret all things to be slightly
negative
that may not be negative um
but i it's not like it's not important
in our
relating um god you're mature
so it's a little different that way like
i don't feel like i have to make
something smaller because it doesn't
feel like it's a big
thing that makes sense my friendships
yeah you don't seem like someone who
wants to talk about
you want to talk more about school or a
book or your relationship or
art or like you just escape you don't
have to be always
just enveloped by you know your work and
all these right
i love talking about the work and
and i love talking about what we can do
in stores we can tell and
i like gossiping at the end of the day
about people at work i like doing that
good but
i don't feel like i need to do it with
everybody right i think for me my um
you know my brother my younger brother
he's always been like we weren't
we didn't get along as kids i mean i
wanted to kill him i think i tried to
kill him as a kid uh he threw
uh pool balls you know those hardball he
he would throw tvs whatever he had
in front of him he would throw at me we
didn't get a llama there came a point
where i remember he was in college he's
like
my boys are watching urban legend man
we're so excited i was like
oh that's cool my brother's excited
about what i'm doing and even when i
made this movie that made no money but i
busted my ass and shot a little movie in
indiana
he came and did it with me he came and
helped me out and even yesterday
yesterday i get an email with a
screenshot of a picture from the movies
like still love watching this movie
man so much fun it just meant a lot to
me it's like you know just a little
little moment do you and your sister
share that does she ever send a little
moment like oh here's me and you i miss
you
i get i have a i have a nephew
now so i get videos of him
that are adorable he's at that age where
you know when they're little and they
have
that hilarious giggle that is so
contagious
so she'll send stuff like that my sister
and i were never i mean
she was my little sister you know i read
her books and
sang songs to her and what'd you sing
what'd you sing to her oh god i
embarrassingly i was a teenager young
teenager like 13
was obsessed with disney songs so i
would just
sing her like little
mermaid songs or whatever
which i will
i knew that was going to happen i don't
think i've ever heard you see i don't
know i think i've heard you sing like
kind of like
insane i'm a terrible singer i just
remember you singing like for fun like
hanging out like you know the song or
you'd be
just coming something or doing something
and yeah but you don't really like to
sing
but no one in your family was sort of um
they weren't you didn't live with
extroverts
no no everyone's an introvert i don't my
dad's the closest to an extrovert in my
family
we are all introverted peeps hmm
so he didn't dance around in his
underwear to make you girls laugh or
like oh
it wasn't that i don't know no no
absolutely not
he'd chuck us around like happily throw
you around
yeah yeah yeah okay that's i i wanted to
make that clear all of a sudden
kristen kirk's dead not like abusive
yeah
yeah yeah i know he threw us around i'm
like holy crap that's an excerpt someone
who doesn't know you who just air
kristen crook's parents he just he threw
us around
i wouldn't do that
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon you guys have to listen to this
magic spoon sent me four boxes all right
i got them right here
i got the blueberry all right i got the
cocoa
what else do i have defrosted right here
frosted fruity
so i had them at my house
and my friend goes whoa what's that my
friend ethan who talks like that whoa
he's gonna get mad but he's a solid
ethan and
joe was over here tom we were socially
distanced that's not important right now
i gave them tastings of each i
shizzle nizzle you not
they were going nuts they're like dude
this tastes like i don't want to say the
name or this tastes like
i feel young dude i'm i swear you you
emailed joe and ethan and tom
they were going nuts on magic spoon
which made me happy i'm like well if
they are a sponsor maybe i can get a
bigger discount for my friends
you know growing up cereal is one of the
best parts of being a kid right ryan oh
yeah
i mean you just wanted to just you
couldn't wait to just down the fruity or
whatever taste of you know all the big
brand names stuff
all the big brand names but we had to
give it up because you know you realize
it's full of sugar
and crap and you just really shouldn't
eat it right yeah the older you get oh
no it's bad for you so
you know obviously i i try to cut down
on the carbs and the
and the sugars and all this stuff and i
realized i can't eat
anything anymore but magic spoon
zero sugar 11 grams of protein
three net grams of carbs in each serving
four flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry look at these beautiful boxes
it makes you feel like you're a kid
again look at that you can tell i've
been destroying it because it's almost
ripped up already sorry magic spoon i
can't be
perfect for you but i'm telling you it's
good that's why the box was ripped open
it tastes amazing it's honestly too good
to be true and um
keto friendly gluten-free grain-free soy
free
low-carb and gmo free and still tastes
freaking great
go to magic magicspoon.com
iou what is it ryan magicspoon.com
iou that's correct and grab a variety
pack and try it today you got to try the
variety pack you got to try them all
be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to get free
shipping and magic spoon is so confident
in their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked and what's the problem guys
magicspoon.com iou and use the code
iou for free shipping we thank magic
spoon
for sponsoring our podcast
you're going back to school and it's
something i really
admire because um i for one just always
try to get out of school
but you're back in school now what are
you studying
okay so i right before getting on this
call with you i just took my final exam
for my art history class uh but i'm just
i'm working towards my bachelor's degree
it's it's something i've sort of wanted
to do since i graduated high school
but i was working and it's just i'm
going very slowly because i'm working as
well
um but yeah i love it i love it and i
don't have to go to class i can do it
all online
but you were going to class before this
happened right no i don't have to go so
queen's university does a full distance
ed program so
everything it's the same class as they
offer on campus they don't offer their
entire
course load but you can select what you
want and then just you
work from home on a computer and
it's a joy it means i can not talk to
people
i can write essays on my own time i'm
really good at being self-directed
so it's perfect for me you have no add
you have no you're focused you can you
could
work for hours and not blink right
yeah i'm very focused you're a straight
a student admit it
currently i am a straight a student i
wasn't always
in high school it got you know it was
mixed but yeah currently i am but it to
be fair to everyone in the world i take
one or maximum three classes a term
most students are taking over five would
you have taken a class if it wasn't
available online
to go to class oh i did that's how i
started this journey
when i was done beauty and the beast i
was like i need to go to school
my brain feels drained so i was doing um
continuing education at the university
of toronto which is like basically me
and 65 year old people
learning about you know the second world
war or
miss like uh mythology or and i took a
creative writing class
and all of that stuff i started and i
was like just flirting with the idea of
actually working toward my degree
and eventually i was just like why not i
can take as long as i want
and i love it and so i just started so
65 year old people are are pretty much
the
the age range around 50 60s
who you're going to class with no now
that i'm in university well right i'm
talking about when you went to class
yeah when i was going to my continuing
ed classes
the people who go to continuing ad are
retirees generally
so nobody recognized you oh gosh no and
you love that
yes because if you would have gone with
a bunch of people your age or younger
you probably would have to deal with oh
hi you're on that
and you some some but the young young
ones they don't really know me
so it's like a it's a funny pocket like
because i'm more exploring
for my bachelor's degree it's really
young people they're like
18 19 20 they're they're babies
uh and they don't know me as much but
honestly i think sometimes when i go to
take an exam
someone will recognize me no one cares
i care i care did you ever decide that
you wanted to learn another language
because your
your dad's uh your mom's trainees
yeah my mom's at chinese origin she
never spoke mandarin or cantonese she
only speaks english
my dad's of dutch heritage and he only
speaks english
but in in canada we take french
for a long time so i took french through
high school but i
i haven't practiced it in a long time
and you still love acting
some of it i do yes burden of truth is
what third season
we're going into our fourth season i go
to work in two weeks
and you play a lawyer is that a lot of
dialogue a lot of tough dialogue
yes it is it's a lot i've basically
become you you were talking on one of
our panels the other day about like
learning your [ __ ] like
weeks in advance i am officially that
person i
will sit i've got like court scenes and
they're normally
through the middle of the night and i'll
have that we are block shooting like 10
pages and it's all me
i'll just sit there for weeks beforehand
studying and studying and studying it's
just so much
and you're going to school i mean going
to school and learning all these things
and trying to keep your grades up and
then memorizing all these lines and
i mean that's a lot i mean do you i mean
do you stress do you do you do
did someone help you with the lines um
eric will sometimes just read lines with
me
at home but then he gets annoyed why
does he get annoyed what is it
well no because i mean who wants to just
read lines for hours on it
he will do it happily but i just don't
want to make him do it forever do you
ever say eric
can you put a little effort into that i
feel like i'm talking to a recorder he
does he puts effort in he acts is he
trying to impress you or something
no he just likes to anything there's all
those apps now too
that you can put it on to your um
yeah with the record right it will say
the lines and then you say yours and
so you use that too wow four seasons
huh i always thought it's my 20th season
on television my 20th season total
of television as a regular 20th because
you did seven of smallville
seven of small four five of the show
called edgemont i did four on beauty and
the beast and this will be my fourth on
this show
that's more than i've done i think i'm
probably at like 14.
i gotta catch up maybe no you don't have
to
tv's tv's a lot you don't seem like
you're really that interested in
pursuing that actively well who knows
but you know the uh the whole virtual
thing we're in this virtual world now so
everybody's zooming
and so you and i and tom we just did a
uh
a smallville virtual how weird is that
for you
it's very weird being on a panel in
person
is much easier because
we can i can see you guys we're there's
no lag
i can get a sense of what you're feeling
or what's going on
when we're in this world it's very
difficult to figure out when there's a
break in conversation
we can't use our bodies as cues to talk
the guys it feels very
disconnected and strange and there's no
audience so i can't tell if they're
bored
if they find something interesting like
there's just so much engagement
when we're in person that we just can't
have it
in this world i really like when um
people
are very forthcoming or very uh they
take the initiative they
sort of say hey so blah and they start
asking stuff because have you ever had
those uh situations where someone's just
staring sitting there looking at you and
you're like hey
how are you good okay uh so you know
sometimes those are hard and i'm sure
for me i could i could do it because
you know i i just like you know me but
you you know you might have a little
tougher time doing that you mean on the
one-on-ones yeah the one-on-ones
yeah i find most people i can just talk
to them
either i can either they want to ask me
questions or they just want me to talk
so i will ask them where they are how
they're doing
these the time goes by very quickly i
don't even
find it yammering for a bit
what's what are the questions you're
asked on a repeated basis
[Music]
i don't actually know the answer to that
which is weird
i can't think of a repeated question
currently i mean you probably get a lot
of lana lane questions
right yeah yes i do i get a lot of that
but some people know that i'm really
really excited about burden of truth so
they'll ask me
about that because either they are
legitimately fans or
they know that i am a fan of the show um
and they'll ask me about scenes or
about how i felt about certain
storylines
but mostly they want to tell me that
they loved the show
and how they felt about it and what it
meant to them and does that
connect with you a lot because i know
when you're caught up in it we all are
like you know
we're doing it we're we don't understand
the impact things can have
you know and we feel like oh this is
silly it's just a tv show people are
risking their lives all over the world
to help people those are the heroes
right but then
you're like when you hear some of these
stories
it it you know it's touching do you are
you ever
i mean do you have to hold back emotion
have you ever been emotional with
someone's uh sort of
of course more when when we're in person
with them
i think people feel more comfortable to
be intimate in those situations maybe
not everybody some people feel safe with
the distance
of the virtual but yeah i mean
and like i feel i i feel
what people are going through i think
that's part of communicating with other
individuals and having any sense of
what's going on for them you've got to
experience as much as you can and what
they're what they're telling you they
experienced
and that's that is emotional for sure
are you what are you doing during this
whole time of uh
you know the pandemic are you do you go
out at all are you
mostly staying home or what are you what
are you doing and how are you uh
what's your reaction towards in terms of
like how you're dealing with how are you
dealing with it well
honestly i um my life's pretty close to
the same as it always is
but the difference is like i i miss
little things i miss going to the movie
theater
i'm miss going to a restaurant i miss
kind of like being in the vicinity of
other people
like we live in cities for a reason
there's something about absorbing the
energy of that city and i miss doing
that but
what i've been most concerned about in
my immediate community is
the businesses that are around so i've
tried to support them so in my
my day-to-day life now we're quite open
in this city
like a lot of restaurants are opening up
blah blah blah so i'll try and go and
eat on people's patios
i don't want to go inside yet um i
support my gym
workout with them out in the park um
you know i just try to engage in that
way otherwise i'm just at home
why do you think canada why do you think
uh you
you're in you're in canada toronto
toronto yeah
why do you think things are working well
there now why do you think in canada
everything's kind of working and opening
what do you think the reason is behind
that
i think there's a bunch of stuff i think
our government never
denied the fact that this was a real
issue
i think that there's a little there's
become
[Music]
more consistency in the messaging i mean
obviously this is
a new virus we've never experienced it
before
science is constantly learning more and
we have to change what we're doing based
on that
um i think that
we have less of this pull to the idea
of personal freedom and i don't
know why that messaging started
happening in the u.s
like somehow your freedom is being
impinged upon um but we don't we don't
seem to have that same problem not that
we don't there are people who are
protesting still
um i don't know i i mean i do think a
big part of it is like having
government officials who are saying that
it's real and that it matters
and that we're in this together right
there's just a mixed message here of
like you know one
you know the president's saying this and
he's not wearing a mask so he's showing
people that hey it's not a big deal then
his scientist is saying another thing
but he's keeping him around even though
he doesn't agree with
it just it's kind of like a you know and
i don't get political in here but that's
just the thing it shouldn't be political
so it's just it shouldn't be and it's
obvious
what we should do and what we need to do
like i i think the fact that has become
so steeped in conspiracy theories
is so crazy well the one thing that gets
me and um
i just don't know how they could think
this is all about um
the election so we're compromising the
health of the entire planet
and every country so we could win an
elect
it's the most asinine thing i could
understand
the russians rigging the whole thing or
that is
fathomable i'm not getting political i'm
saying
it is not political i feel like george
sees scott it is
not in the files that's how he talked i
don't know if you know that
it is not so okay so it sounds like you
got [ __ ]
going on it's you're together because
there is just i think everybody has come
together in the
the um the nation of canada and they
have said
hey this is the deal let's wear masks
let's be respectful and uh this will
blow over
as opposed to i ain't doing that yeah
and i think the other part of it too and
this is changing right now a little bit
but
the government supported people with
money
people have been getting money during
this time from the government so they
don't have to feel the pressure
to go back to work whereas i feel like
you guys have been
left in the lurch a little bit in that
way and for people to
survive they need to go back to the
workplace i think in both countries
we're dealing with a lot of
um like you're seeing income disparity
and there are certain people who don't
have privilege
and who do have to go to work regardless
but i do think canada has
financially supported individuals
which on the ground means that you don't
you really don't have to go and risk
your kids lives or risk your life
by going out i just want everybody to
live i want people that were you know
i just want uh i want to get back to the
way things were and uh in order to do
that sometimes you have to go against
what you think is maybe
or maybe what you want to do like you
know i don't want to do this but i'm
going to do it sometimes that's what we
do we do that all the time in a
relationship you know what
i'm going to compromise and if you don't
compromise the relationship's going to
implode
everything implodes when you don't
compromise and if you don't respect and
love
it will implode things don't go right
well they don't go well you plan to
study forensic science
is that because you love watching stuff
that's really dark and cold case files
and stuff like that what is it that like
you thought about that i know you didn't
do that but what was it
i was interested in criminology
mostly and it was because i was
interested
in human psychology
which is the same reason i loved acting
um
i was obsessed with understanding why
people thought the way they did
what drove people to commit
crimes or to to be violent or
you know just to exist the way they did
at all and i i was
very fascinated
with understanding that aspect of human
nature better
and that's why i really wanted to do
that but did you watch that dark stuff
or you kind of like you don't go
i didn't i didn't when i was in high
school i i wasn't really
allowed to i mean i was interested in it
like
when i read books i i was interested in
books that were
that explored a little bit more
tumultuous emotions
and you know darker themes i suppose but
it wasn't ever like
it was never like serial killers or
things like that
um but yeah definitely interested
in in the kind of the darkness of human
nature what do you do
to um stay straight in terms of like
your mind straight keeping things
together keeping because we talked about
that in the beginning how
you're sort of even keeled you're you
know you try not to get too upset you're
trying to be overwhelmed not spreading
yourself too thing but what do you do
what do you uh are you going back to
karate
like you did when you were a kid i mean
what what are you doing physically
mentally what is what is your routine i
exercise
how often that's really um
i probably take one day off a week
so i'll exercise it won't be excessive i
don't excessively exercise but like i'll
do cardio
or i will go to a weightlifting you know
class
um so i'll do that is about six days a
week sometimes a little less depending
on my course load if i'm busy with other
things or if i'm working
and how long is a class an hour an hour
yeah i don't normally work out more than
an hour
how do you feel when you don't do it
when you don't get
like particularly like um it
doesn't feel good there's energy that
needs to be expended and i'm not doing
that so
exercise is a huge part of my mental
health i think and it always has been i
mean and i've been active since i was
you know a little kid it's huge a huge
part of my family's life
it's just what i learned how to do um
yeah and i think mentally i think i
don't do it
as actively as maybe i used to but it's
also practicing
not going into like thought spirals
i'll actively pull myself out of thought
spirals
i think everybody listening we do the
same thing whenever we work out or we go
for a walk or we do anything that
we exert energy you know bad energy
whatever it is
we know we see immediately that this is
this is good like you could see
it unless like you've never worked out
in your life and the first time you're
gonna start it's gonna be like tough and
shitty and there's nothing good about it
but the knowing how you feel but then
there's some kind of psychology where
we know we're gonna feel better when we
do this but we don't
and then we feel shitty and then we
wonder why we're feeling shitty it makes
a
huge huge difference and then because
i've been running which i have
i've never done previously i'm not a
runner and now i've kind of become a
runner
there's a meditative aspect to it as
well which i think is really helpful
finding and i think that's that is also
the same thing i was talking about
before finding ways not to go into
thought spirals
i think running allows for the space to
create like a
meditation where you know you can watch
thoughts come and go and you can feel
your body go through tension and release
like it's it's like a
i think it's a good practice for me
personally does eric
your boyfriend does he does he exercise
too as much as you do
he he does it right now because he's in
a writer's room um
but he does now he didn't before but for
him
and he wouldn't mind me saying this for
him for his mental
health it makes it makes a huge impact
in his life his anxiety gets
really intense if he's not exercising
yeah and you you obviously notice it
you're like hey
you're you know you could see those
things i wish i had somebody there with
me who would say hey
go do this somebody to also be held
accountable like you you have to be held
accountable for your own [ __ ] but it's
nice to
like rely on someone else to say get the
[ __ ] up and go for a run
you know you're gonna feel better and if
you don't i have to sit here and deal
with your [ __ ]
right in a way i mean and you have to
deal with your [ __ ] just go for a
run go do something
i wish i had somebody here to just
remind me uh
uh that yeah that i should exercise it's
hard when you're inside your own head
because you're dealing with yourself
it's it's really hard sometimes to get
outside of yourself so
having anybody who can be like i think
you're doing this thing right now
you can be even you can see it like they
can shine the light on something
um and then how you choose to react to
that is whatever but
yeah i think that it does help to have
have
help it does are you able to uh oh
you're pretty open uh
with your feelings do you pretty much
will you feel something you don't hold
it in for a month and then go
hey remember last month when you said
what what last month
i'm a dude i can't remember what i had
for break you know what i mean do you
tend to like bring things up like you
know what
this happened i just want to bring it up
it bothered me a little bit are you able
to do that with anybody
yeah now i think now i am if we had had
this conversation when i was 21
i would have said no i can't i have no
idea
how to talk about my feelings talk about
what's bothering me
even acknowledge that something is
bothering me then that i have
a right to have something bother me but
now
i feel fairly capable
most of the time being first of all i
can acknowledge when i'm feeling
something
i can see when i'm making something up i
can address it
so it's made a big difference in my life
in my relationships i imagine i'm much
easier to be around now
you've always been easy to be around
krista
inside of you is brought to you by
better help online counseling i
love these guys i love people that help
people you know
and um you know uh especially in this
climate we've talked about it and
obviously in the last few weeks i've had
some personal things happen and
you got to talk to someone i don't care
how tough you think you are the toughest
people in the world will talk to a
therapist and to me
i think it's vital i think that's what
we talk about on this podcast and
if you think you're depressed you're
feeling anxious you're freaking not
alone
we are with you trust me we're with you
i
deal with it we all deal with it don't
think you're alone
but uh it's easy to get overwhelmed and
better help offers licensed professional
counselors who are trained to listen and
help
talk with your counselor in a private
online environment your own convenience
from wherever you're comfortable
better help counselors have expertise in
in many areas
i said anxiety and therapy but
grief anger issues self-esteem
they have it covered better helping give
you access to help that may not be
available in your area
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs
and you get matched with your counselor
in under 48 hours
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages thank god
for that
everything you share is confidential you
know that you don't have to worry about
anything if for any reason you're
unhappy with your counselor you request
a new one at any time no additional
charge
join the million plus people taking
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced better
help counselor in fact so many people
have been using better help they're
currently recruiting additional
counselors in all 50
states betterhelp is an affordable
option and our listeners get 10
off your first month with the discount
code inside
get started today at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp
inside talk to a therapist online
and get help this episode is brought to
you by the jordan harbinger show
a podcast guys that i really think you
should check out especially if you like
this podcast i think he does a great job
so personable and uh if you're a fan of
high quality
uh you know fascinating podcast hosted
by interesting people well
jordan harpinger i recommend our
listeners check out the danny trejo
episode i find that guy very interesting
and jordan
has a it just gives a really incredible
interview with danny trejo so you should
check that out
and the the mark cuban and kevin systrom
interview is uh
pretty fascinating one of the founders
of instagram you're going to want to
hear that and there's a
he talks about everything and uh he like
i said he's so personable
what i like about the jordan harbinger
show is that he covers stories like
uh just fascinating stories that i
wouldn't even think of that are pretty
amazing like
how a professional art forger somehow
made
millions of dollars while being chased
by the feds in the mafia
uh he really dives in which means it's a
lot of work like he does a lot of
research
you know i i admire that we really enjoy
the show
and we think you will as well search for
the jordan harbinger show that's
h-a-r-b as in boy i n
as in nancy g-e-r on apple podcast
spotify
or wherever you listen to podcast
the jordan harbinger show have you
experienced any loss thus far in life in
37 years any loss that's been kind of
like that you sort of
something that you know because for me i
think it's been i've had two losses
in 48 years which i'm lucky because
people have i mean i have a friend ethan
who i love who lost his parents at a
very young age and it breaks my heart
and you can just see the love he still
has for them and
um you know loss is something that like
uh you know can be devastating and how
you deal with it and how it makes you
stronger and
have you had to deal with any of that
well
i i mean my grandparents have all passed
away but
i think like my grandmother that i was
closest to
she died when i was quite young um
and it had a big impact on my life but i
was six
you know um very different
and as as an adult
like when it comes to the finality of
loss
in regards to like death for instance i
i
haven't i haven't had anyone very very
close to me
pass in a way that was traumatic for me
um
but i mean i've dealt with loss in less
permanent ways
um relationships you know yeah loss of
relationships like
multiple friendships that have proven to
be
you know really destructive in my life
um
so things like that i've had to face and
and i think it's certainly
given me a more deep experience of life
yeah
and it's funny because the relationships
you know you think of death when you
think of life but
a relationship it is or you know it
feels like death sometimes
i i've had those feelings in my stomach
where i'm like oh my gosh i can't
function because of
of this uh of a breakup or whatever and
it's like you know that's
it's incredible it can be incredibly
painful something that you have to keep
in check and you know i think it is
painful
it's just a different kind of
again i haven't had anyone really close
to me past that isn't you know a
grandparent
but the loss of death i think is very
different i mean you could speak to that
more than i
could than the loss of relationship that
you're grappling with different things
sure all right this is called [ __ ]
talking with kristen crook these are my
lovely patrons
and uh they're big supporters of the
podcast and they have some
this is rapid fire so you could go as
fast as you want if you feel like you
need to talk about something here we go
this is easy i'm bad at rapid fire it's
my worst i like this
spot right here keep their hands like
that this is like uh yeah this is
back to beauty and the beast here it is
it's very uh what's that movie with the
eyes the
hands and the eyes um pam's labrador
dan's labyrinth
i love that you know that horror movie
and i love i love you
okay all right [ __ ] talking kristen
crook jamie c did scotty really know
scotty really know what i'm sorry i
should know that it's from a movie
michael
jackson he didn't know okay there you go
jamie he really didn't know lisa h i
absolutely love beauty and the beast do
you feel they could have ended the
series better i know it was canceled
like so many other great shows but i
felt there was so much more story to
tell
and should have been given a proper
send-off i
kind of liked the way we ended the show
but yeah i think there were always more
stories to tell
with with that with that show was that a
hard series to shoot
um yeah i mean it was
a nighttime show it was a beast he was
a military experiment oh i saw it yeah
he was really good-looking good-looking
guy yes he's a good-looking guy okay
just like well i wanted to say it i
didn't even ask if you wanted to say it
i just i noticed he was a
handsome guy steph
i always do that i admire you know i'm
easy like i had a dream about uh bradley
cooper
last week i woke up and i was like i
dreamt about brother it wasn't sexual or
anything
but i just remember going man that's a
cool guy that bradley cooper
anyway uh steph between smallville
burden of truth edgemont beauty and the
beast
honestly which role is closer to how you
are as a person
i think i think
probably um
[Music]
joanna from burden is closest to me but
i'm not as intense as her
she's really really intense but you also
grew on each show too so it's not really
it's not an easy question because
smallville the first season
then you look at you maybe smallville
later or a show later oh definitely not
lana
no i definitely am not her no who said
you were i'm not katherine
i just think i'm probably closest to
joanna
oh maybe i'm like laurel actually maybe
i'm like laurel
she's from benchmark i mean yeah
edgemont carly h
as somebody who's naturally shot shies
away from the spotlight how did you
handle those first few months of fame on
smallville i've talked to you about this
a long time ago and have you learned to
deal with it in the in the decades later
so
uh because i remember yeah handled it
terribly i really struggled
with it and i think
part of how i've handled it actually
this kind of ties back into what we're
talking about about overwhelm
i i kind of changed my life i i didn't
take
certain roles i didn't do as much press
i kind of pulled myself away
from the spotlight a little bit because
i
didn't like how famous we were when we
were on smallville
yeah it scared you it wasn't for you i
wanted all of it and
you know tom wanted part of it and uh
you know i think i want you know what it
was
it was nice to be on a show finally that
people were like you know they they
looked at you and it was
i i'm not gonna lie i mean when people
were like
you know they loved the character and i
could tell the writers loved the
character and the other cast members
appreciated my work it was just really
nice it was nice to get that sort of
feeling of like
hey dude you're doing something right
you're on a good show you're good
so yeah i mean it was kind of nice
good with people like i don't think
people scare you
like they scare me sometimes sure yeah
which makes it easier to deal with
people paying attention to you
yeah i'm an attention [ __ ] sophie m hi
kristen
hello do you have a favorite line you
got to deliver as lana lang i don't even
remember lines from
people i don't remember any of the lines
how about the one clark you're gorgeous
i want you
i like that i don't think i ever said
that mm-hmm you didn't say that lex
i really like that lex i love you you're
so hot
i don't think you said that one either
janelle b last one what type of books do
you like to read the most
and what is your absolute favorite go-to
book to read
here she lit up she lit up look at her
she's on fire she
loves reading hey listen i have been
actively
broadening my reading scope so i've been
getting more into science fiction
fantasy
which wasn't my thing but i'm loving mk
jemisin
she is a genius and amazing um
super creative and unique writer
and then i i think i'd normally read
like contemporary fiction
i live in that world um but i also love
you know going back to my olden times i
love classical literature too so like
the bronte sisters i really enjoyed that
kind of tortured
read um but there's a book
for quarantine while we're still in it
for a while longer that i think is
really excellent peter benchley's jaws
what sorry sorry i jumped in and said
peter benchley's jaws
what is it emily st john mandel wrote
this book called station 11
and it's about um
the world going into a pandemic and
it escalates more than ours has and it
follows import like a theater troop
a shakespeare theater troupe that goes
through the united states in a caravan
and it's really complex and the
characters are fascinating and it's
hopeful
it's like a pandemic read that leaves
you
hopeful for humanity's future not
devastated and in despair
there's also this horror movie you
should check out no i'm just kidding
that's all i watch i mean i watch a lot
of horror movies there's a movie relic i
liked i liked uh
um i liked hereditary it follows there
was a new one called host where it's a
zoom call
for the the creditor is pretty good uh
there's it's a zoom call
it's called host host it's new and it's
all filmed like these five girls are
zooming each other
and then horror happens and it worked i
kind of liked it
i didn't tell you this i don't think but
um we went to go
visit uh eric's cousin and actually
someone i did gymnastics with for a long
time
um in amsterdam and this was
a while ago now but her partner is
a director and loves hor they both love
horror so they gave
they made a crash course because i was
like i don't get it i don't get horror i
don't like it
i don't understand it and it was like
basically
a whole list of horror movies to watch
from the classics through like
you know more gory stuff to like weird
did you watch them
yeah we watched pretty much every single
one and i've come to
really i think appreciate the form there
are things i don't love like
i don't love you know the saws of the
world
but but i love what you can
do in horror i especially think i really
like the older the older
alien he's like alien please say that
so good and as you love it that's just a
kick-ass woman at the end
yeah that's great how about i mean jaws
the shining exorcist oh man
jaws oh the shining obviously
i i really i mean i love like old like
psycho i love
oh i'm telling you that scene when he
comes down with a knife in the
basement at the end is one of the most
horrifying moments in horror history i i
to this day that scene is just
incredible it really is yeah so
i like this i like that you're
experimenting with horror you just
you know you maybe i'll have to start
reading
all right so i'm gonna have to start
reading give me a couple of books that
you think i could actually
read maybe uh if they have pictures or
if there are less than 200 pages
what i read a horror book called only
good indians
okay it's a hardcover right now i'm not
sure if you would like it like because i
don't know what you would like to read
it's pretty
short but it kind of it follows
um a group of men
who are indigenous
and they have some of them have left the
reservation but there's like it takes
place in the states
and they did something in the past that
has come back to haunt
is it scary tracking them all down what
and it's scary
it's a horror yeah okay send me that no
just email me and i'll go i'll go get it
okay i'll email you this has been fun
you know it's funny because i know i i
i'm sure you were thinking the same
thing
you were probably thinking oh what is he
gonna ask me i mean we talked like
a long time ago but this time i have you
on film we could see your
nice face and we could talk and we got
to talk about a lot of other things
we did you know we kind of delved into
little things and it was uh
i always loved talking to you i'm
talking to you too
yeah it's easy right it is easy yeah
because i know you don't like interviews
all the time
i don't you're correct i don't but i
like talking to people that i know
okay what's that globe behind you
what country is it on what continent
it's not like a real
it's like old and oh it's like uh
yeah it's like almost like uh what's uh
what's the old time things uh where they
were
you know like genghis khan and uh it's
like it's just cool
it's just cool show-and-tell all right i
love you i'll talk to you soon
yeah she's just a good person isn't she
delight she is
she's uh i you know it's just i always
when you talk to someone like kristen i
always feel like uh
it's not that she makes me feel this way
i think just i
make myself feel this way but it's sort
of like i'm like i've got to do better
i've got to be a better person i've got
kristin's got it together
you know that's why i think i do this
show because i'm hoping that people
don't exactly have it together all the
time and
i think that that's true even for
kristen i don't think she has it
together all the time she has her
moments they get in arguments you know
you know in the interview we hear this
stuff
but uh it's nice and it's it's always
nice to talk to someone i've worked with
and known so long and uh
so there you have it another big shout
out to
all the patrons out there um again the
stage at show is uh this saturday 2 p.m
and 6 p.m rob danson and i are going to
play
a lot of originals covers left on laurel
tunes my phone's ringing it happens
and um that stage you go to stage.com
type in rose and mom and dance and
there's two shows get tickets
huge prizes you won't believe it it's
fun a lot of virtual events coming up
and uh the online store inside of your
online store you can still get
beach towels sandals oh i don't have the
sandals out yet though
flip-flops i didn't put those up yeah
but uh still got new v-neck
fitted shirts for the ladies and uh crew
nick for the guys
because guys don't want v-necks although
i have friends that still wear v-necks i
had a v-neck phase i
stopped that we all did yeah it's gone
though i don't know if it's gone i think
it when i had a nice chest
i think i like to itch and i don't get
into it
i don't have the right arrangement of
hairs for it though are you not hairy
no can i see your chest not at this
moment no okay i'll show you later
oh yeah okay uh patrons
i guess the patrons are getting the
shout outs now i do love them many of
these names i just wrote letters to
that's true should we do should we have
sort of a build up like a drum roll
for this for the patrons now can you do
kind of a little drumroll
yeah all right here it goes oh yeah here
we go
and nancy d mary b leah s trisha f
cerave little lisa yukiko
jill e brian h lauren g nico p angelina
g
robin s jerry w emily k bobby robert b
jason w stephen j kristen k not kristin
krug kristen k
maybe that's kristen crook is it
possible kristen crook is he no
no i didn't tell you she wouldn't be a
patron amelia oh allison l
tom and jess jay it'd be nice if welling
was a patron
he would just give me [ __ ] the whole
time lucas m raj
[Music]
emily s cjp samantha m hamza
hamza b jennifer n that's not naniarello
that's jennifer n
jackie p stacy b carly t jennifer s
janelle b
carrie b taba the 272 not to be confused
with down the 273.
thank you kimberly e crystal h mike e
marissa no no no no
ramira beth b kristoff san diego am
sarah f
chad w leanne p rachen it's really
rachel but rachen
ray a maya p i just zoomed with
everybody i had a big zoom of like 50 of
the top tier members
and we all zoomed it up it was great and
i got to see everybody's face oh my god
he had 50 people on one zoom
50 and i was there for like over an hour
and a half and it was it was it was
awesome exhausting but awesome
i think they were they loved it and i
loved it it made me happy
maya p maya p megan d jennifer c maddie
s
tiffany i kendrick f ashley e margie m
thomas t
matt w belinda and benjamin r
lisa j kevin v robert s joy w mike w
james r chris h snow r noah k
sean v osborne h what ospion osbjorn
i was born i was born i was born to love
you
i was born to lick your face i was born
that's from cali shout out
dave h i uh again guys patrons
well i couldn't do it without you thanks
for the extra support and everybody out
there listening just the fact that you
guys listen to me
every week means a ton to me i love
doing what i'm doing i love working with
this guy sitting across from me i love
bryce
thanks to westwood one for really uh
getting the podcast out there and giving
this a real shot and um
live your best life you know all right
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
each and every one of you this has been
[Music]
fun